[موسيقى]
لا يوجد امه من الامم اهتمت بتفاصيل
السماء ومعالم الارض مثل الامه العربيه
فلا يوجد نجمه في السماء ولا رمله في
الارض ولا وادي ولا تل ولا جبل الا وضعوا
له اسما يدل على ما سمي به فالاوديه لها
مسمياتها تدل على جغرافيتها او تاريخها او
ما تتسم بوادي عرعر سمي بهذا لانه يعرعر
الارض بقوته ووادي الحمض المسمى باضم لانه
يضم المياه في جوفه ووادي حنيفه نسبه الى
بني حنيفه ووادي الرمه لانه يروم كل ما
وقع امامه وادي الرمه
ابنه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاوديه اما تنتهي في بحار اوديت تهامه
وجبال الحجاز وكذلك اليمن وسلطنه عمان او
تنتهي في قاع منخفض محاط بالمرتفعات من كل
جوانب فيفيض الماء منها ولهذا تسمى فيضه
فيضه نور فيضه الخفس فيضه الكسر وكذلك
ثياب الحر بالمدينه وتبوك وحايل وعرعر
وفياظه بالقصيم واذا تبخر الماء منها دبه
الحياه في عروقها وبدا النور في الربيع
النور في قلبي وبين جوانحي فعلامه اخشى
السيارات في الظلمه اني انا الناي الذي لا
ينتهي انغامه ما دام
في الاحيائي
[موسيقى]